[Music]
Victor a seaman achieved his dream in
January he signed for valves berg
training went well with the german side
and in May the eighteen-year-old
Nigerian striker made his debut in the
Bundesliga it's been every youngster
dream in Africa to be a professional and
to play for one of the best league in
the world I started when I was when I
was a kid every play every African
player you see in Europe played on the
street so mine is not different I play
on the street also football is like a
religion in Nigeria thousands of young
people play it in the streets of the
country's biggest city Lagos the better
players managed to make it into a team
and many are extremely ambitious
but I mean what best I want to make my
family proud
no I want to take my father's name my
son name to be known all about the world
if I see the chance of going so you know
I'm going to go because I believe the
game is not being played in Europe in
their own country young Nigerian
footballers are relegated to the
sidelines in this suburb of Lagos for
example a football pitch was until
recently the heartbeat of the community
but real estate speculators are now
building a shopping center between the
morning and we cleaned it even to to
sell I say fun - what is - to become a
football a new tomorrow a dream this is
where Isaiah Lewis can help he is
passionate about Nigerian youth football
and has even organized a football film
festival to promote the game in his
homeland
he is also a crucial bridge between
street footballers and club officials
handing young players a chance to make
it into the big time just like Victor a
seaman he was spotted by Vosburgh
because his Nigerian club have had a
tie-up with European clubs for several
years I'm very lucky to admit this this
these guys I'm walking with my dream is
to play football I have not only mine
done to to play football because I don't
know how my life would have been if I
haven't been a professional footballer
and I'm really grateful his success
gives hope to other young players on the
streets of Lagos each pursuing a dream
of one day becoming a star